speaking about wins the San Antonio
Spurs only had 22 wins last season now
they have number one overall draft pick
Victor wanyama you see how tough it is
when teams go to San Antonio have to
play in that building and a team coached
by Greg papovich one of the best to ever
do it if not the best of all time what
are your expectations for the Spurs this
season do they get past that 22 win mark
yes I think they get past 22 wins I
think you know in terms of are they in
the playoff picture I I don't know I
think they'll be better than what people
think but wimi brings energy and
excitement there and this team well
coached they're going to play hard and
and I really think he's going to get
better as the year goes on he is
figuring things out you know it's coming
at him 100 miles an hour and they're
figuring out how to use him GRE papovich
moving him around taking advantage of
his skill set a guy who's that tall that
skilled that talented I expect him to
get better and his team to get better
but they're in the Western Conference so
I don't expect a lot but they're going
to compete and they're going to play
hard every night
maybe a little bit similar to what we
saw last year from OKC a young team uh
had a had a star in SGA not saying wimy
is on that level yet as a superstar but
just they played hard every night you
had to beat OKC and they they weren't
going to beat themselves and I think the
same thing applies with this San Antonio
Spurs team yeah especially being coached
by a guy like Greg papovich where do you
see the Spurs going the next few years
with the talent that they oh I think if
they just keep a massive Talent building
around this young man they're going to
be one of the teams because you got to
think about it when they're ready to win
in a couple Seasons some of those teams
like the Lakers and the Clippers they're
going to be on their down slide now
you're still GNA have to deal with
Memphis you still gonna have to deal
with New Orleans because those teams on
the up and coming but some of the Star
Wars teams that we're used to seeing up
there the Lakers and other teams like
that they're going to start fing the
thing that I like about the San Antonio
team and the coach step they got to
figure out how to use this guy and I say
this for this reason people say well
they had David Robins they had Tim
Duncan no he's nothing like David
Robinson and Tim Duncan they were
Sinners and power forward Victor is a
small forward so Pap's gonna have to go
into his bag of tricks and he's going to
watch this game Victor got in fou T
early did he put up great stats for the
few minutes that he played but they're
going to have to figure out Grant how to
play him a little different go back and
look at Rasheed Wallace Kevin garet
Chris Bosch you're going to have to put
him at that high post and give him some
space room to operate because you can't
play him like David Robinson Tim and Sam
I remember in 2008 Kevin Durant's first
season with the then Seattle SuperSonics
we played them in their home opener uh
when I was with Phoenix and we were
thinking man this is crazy this guy's
610 611 doing things on the floor we
haven't seen guys do once he gets there
dangerous just keep building slowly be
patient do the right thing and it's
going to happen again in San Antonio
have you ever seen a guy like that
that's 74 that can move the way that Wy
can yeah ched hram the guy in OKC think
about we got three guys in the NBA now
pingis hram and Victor
7273 that are freakish athletic and
skill off the chart they all can shoot
the three they all can dribble they all
can pass they Elite athletes we've never
seen anything like this in the NBA and
I'm going to make another prediction all
three of those guys may be All Stars
this year think about that OKC is going
to be good Victor is going to play with
the young guys and he may have a chance
to sneak into Allstar team and then you
know look at porzingis he's going to be
on the best team with the most Talent so
he's going to have an excellent chance
of being an Allstar because they're
going to have the best record if they
don't have the best record going into
the break something's wrong yeah